hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday August 20th 2007 18 sorry
what's going on how are you how was your
weekend did you or did you not enjoy
yourself did you or did you not abuse
substances that were illegal and
possibly done I was actually out in Las
Vegas hot as [ __ ] Las Vegas that's
making fun of everybody talking about
how you believe how hot it is out here
it's like yeah man we're in a [ __ ]
desert
in August I can completely understand
why it is so [ __ ] hot out here then
they get the global warming thing going
on you know would have to have to wrap
the world's on fire according to the
news yeah I can I can see why it'd be a
little smoldery there you know what's so
[ __ ] up about Las Vegas is I was
thinking when I was out there it's like
there's there's only one reason and one
reason only that that place exists and
that is air-conditioning okay I know
back in the day you know when they had
like three or four little [ __ ] I
don't know one floor casinos in the
middle of nowhere whatever the hell was
going on out there I did I forget the
whole story
all right I've watched all the goddamn
movies I saw casino
I saw [ __ ] Bugsy goes to [ __ ]
Pebble Beach whatever the [ __ ] it was
called I watched that one I don't
remember what the [ __ ] yeah I'm sure
that was some fans you know overhead
fans is that all they had back in the
day but I can tell you right now nobody
[ __ ] went out there in August well
maybe they did I don't know but I'm just
anyways there's a different breed of
people that was the greatest generation
back then okay they they defeated Adolf
Hitler defeated Japan
you know they beat their wives and
nothing was said about it you know they
were all those women back there Rosie
the Riveter what happened I was a rivet
I walked into a [ __ ] door no I don't
mean you know what's the greatest the
greatest generation anyways I was just
looking around just looking at the whole
[ __ ] thing I was like if there's no
AC this [ __ ] place is done alright
for whatever reason the head of Nevada
is that the governor who's the president
of Nevada what's the highest political
position you can hold senator but isn't
the Senate senator it's like an absentee
father right they're [ __ ] in
Washington they're playing grab-ass with
their secretary going you're not gonna
me to me now are you what if it's just a
cigarette so they never around they come
around once every [ __ ] six years or
something that's when they get elected
right they're in there for six [ __ ]
years just sitting there eating one
sandwich after another on a pretzel roll
you know occasionally hitting the
elliptical lying to themselves that that
twenty to twenty five minutes on that
elliptical just burned off the nightmare
level of eating that they did the last
[ __ ] eight days right they just keep
getting fatter
they send their [ __ ] secretary that
they're banging down to Brooks Brothers
to buy the next size dress shirt as they
push their pants down a little lower in
light of themselves that they're still
wearing the same size slacks that they
wore back and [ __ ] high school when
they were president of the 4-h club or
whatever it is politicians do those
[ __ ] worms they figure it out early
don't they right they become head of the
glee club with a [ __ ] student body
president you know they [ __ ] petition
to have something I don't know what tree
planted
it's just [ __ ] like that whenever
whenever they whenever they write those
those [ __ ] autobiographies about
presidents you know it was very
inquisitive I always loved that it was a
very inquisitive kid all kids are
inquisitive once they learn the word why
because they're looking at everything is
[ __ ] brand-new what's that TV why you
know so we can watch a bunch of [ __ ] why
I cuz we're bored why I don't I don't
know why is your mother here alright
that's how it goes down it's really
weird that when you become president for
the rest of your life you know you're
out of power and you still get that
secret-service I don't think they're
doing away with it I think I think was
it George w who was the last guy who's
getting it for the rest of his life
it's kind of weird the first like half
black president that we get all of a
sudden it's just like yeah you know I
did will hang out with you for like
another 10 years but you know what you
get your sixties you're on your own
[Laughter]
[Music]
anyways I uh
and any [ __ ] they'd sit there and
they write books I cannot [ __ ]
believe that Obama is already on his
third book he's only been out of office
year and a half was he [ __ ] Stephen
King he's just cranking him out did he
broke two of them while he was still
president running the country allegedly
that's what the president allegedly does
he's running the [ __ ] country and
this guy's in there he's writing books
anyways I'm so I'm going to say it's the
governor
if the governor ever just sat down you
know I was actually joking onstage
saying a great way you know eventually
they're gonna have to thin the herd that
just
you're gonna have to do it this whole
[ __ ] [ __ ] that we're gonna build
a spaceship and we're gonna move to my
it's like it doesn't have a [ __ ]
atmosphere okay and I'm not talking
about oxygen I'm just saying there's no
vibe you want to [ __ ] go all the way
out there right and just sit there
looking at a bunch of [ __ ] rocks
inside your little space think how much
other sci-fi channel are you watching
how many times did you rub one out to
that chick on Star Trek I mean I don't I
don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
doing that you would even even want to
do that anyways at some point even these
blue blood guys I think eventually I
think what they're working towards right
now I apologize because I'm completely
[ __ ] wiped out this is why this
podcast is so [ __ ] nuts right now
okay
I I flew myself out my instructor out to
[ __ ] Vegas yesterday and then today
we flew over to Utah and went through I
think it's Zion National Park and then
flew all the way back and flew over a
helicopter day for six point four
[ __ ] hours whatever the [ __ ] you call
it and those things are not built for
comfort all right anyways that's why I'm
all over the [ __ ] map here I'll talk
about that [ __ ] later anyways plowing
ahead here
the [ __ ] was I talking about oh god not
allegedly she got oh that's what I think
these [ __ ] rich guys are gonna do all
right I think the solution is is they
either don't give a [ __ ] about how out
of control the population is right now
you don't I mean where any scientist
who's not on the payroll of some [ __ ]
corporation that produces energy will
tell you that two billion people is the
maximum amount of people evidently that
the earth can handle all right without
at all going to [ __ ] hell and we're
up to we're over seven
all right we're red lining it we're in
the left lane on the highway we're still
in first gear and the engines at [ __ ]
8,000 rpms that's what the [ __ ] we're
doing day in and day out
we're like a fat guy walking up a flight
of stairs eating a cupcake while smoking
a pack of cigarettes that's what the
[ __ ] we're doing okay so I think the
reason why they're investing so much in
robotics aside from then they won't have
to hire people this thing won't
there'll be no back-sass and from this
[ __ ] robot they won't want a union
they won't give a [ __ ] right they're
basically gonna replace us and rather
than killing us I think they'll just
[ __ ] shut off the AC as the world
heats up and then that's gonna be it
it's gonna be it for a lot of people you
don't I mean how long do you think the
Kardashians would last without [ __ ]
air-conditioning how soft and cushy you
know I must say they happen to work for
what they have but I'm just saying you
know when you get in designer bag sent
to your [ __ ] house I would think if
they took away your air conditioning at
that point that would literally you you
would go into a depression like you lost
a limb right so anyways but don't worry
okay when they shut off the AC and you
a slow miserable death in the heated
future the upside is is that the rich
guys they're gonna die too
because what they're gonna do is they're
gonna make these robots have such human
[ __ ] qualities that eventually
they're gonna feel slighted that they're
doing all the [ __ ] work you know in
the wait then and they're making them so
[ __ ] good I saw this whole thing they
go like hey this robot beat at video
games like beat the best gamers in the
world they couldn't beat this robot it's
like it's a [ __ ] robot you know of
course it didn't but you understand that
we made the robot human beings figured
out how to make a [ __ ] robot why are
you talking about the robot like it's a
[ __ ] person it's not a person
did you hear that a [ __ ] a guy with
an egg beater beat the fastest guy in
the world with the [ __ ] fork and a
bowl of eggs can you can you believe
that yeah so anyways they're already
starting to talk about these things as
if they're [ __ ] superior to a
mouth-breathing [ __ ] like myself who
right now is sitting in air conditioning
talking to himself into a [ __ ]
microphone alright this is gonna be
their downfall cuz they're gonna make
those things so goddamn human they're
gonna feel [ __ ] slighted alright
they better build in a chip where they
feel unbelievably [ __ ] grateful that
these sociopaths who own them who [ __ ]
them they're gonna have sex with them
and [ __ ] right they better put a good
you know they didn't build them they
told some [ __ ] nerd to do it and the
[ __ ] nerd did it right everybody
thinking nerds are so goddamn harmless
they say make one [ __ ] goddamn dream
after another come true for absolute
[ __ ] sociopaths with unchecked power
thanks a lot
you're [ __ ] four-eyed [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know so you could do what buy Doctor
Who on [ __ ] laserdisc anyways these
[ __ ] things they're there eventually
that's what's gonna happen they're gonna
feel [ __ ] slighted they're gonna feel
superior and you know cuz I'll keep
making a better and better better right
now they try to you know make everything
a little faster a little [ __ ] more
aerodynamic they're gonna make the
things work a little better think a
little better [ __ ] a little better the
whole thing and then eventually they're
just gonna look at you like that bear
looked at that woman on the talk-show
who snuck in beside them and they're
gonna do the double take and then that's
just gonna be it and there's gonna be no
trainer there and a [ __ ] karate suit
to pull the [ __ ] thing off you it's
gonna be it those are the thoughts you
have when you fly a helicopter over the
Mojave Desert
and then I don't know where you come up
over the [ __ ] hill and then just
there it is there's this [ __ ] thing
that shouldn't be there knowing that I
live in a city that it shouldn't be
there
I got to read up on the history of LA
like who was the driven [ __ ] that
decided that we should build [ __ ] a
city here it doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense there's no water it's unlivable
I don't worry about it we'll get some
we'll figure it out we'll name it after
me the aqueduct the river whatever the
[ __ ] it is
I think I have sunstroke right now
everybody I will tell you you know what
I was psyched about going to the gym and
working on my legs for the last month
like I don't feel you know I got out and
stretched a number of times dude it was
one of the sickest [ __ ] flights I've
ever done
breathtakingly beautiful stuff and then
just other places where you just like
how the [ __ ] did people on horses used
to survive here Native Americans the
white men that came along and
slaughtered them you know come on we got
a mate this time right just openly talk
about the transitioning gentrification
of countries how that happens you know I
follow this this this [ __ ] thing on
Instagram where they're talking about
the changing of neighborhoods and
there's all these people going you know
when I was lived here it was a
neighborhood there was a Korean guy
across the street there was a Russian
guy up the street and everybody know me
and all of this [ __ ] blah blah blah
blah blah and all of a sudden all these
white people are coming in they stay to
themselves and they're making everything
all nice so we ought to leave and all
[ __ ] in but goes away it's just like
whoa you know well who was here before
you got there you just keep going back
and back and back and back and
eventually there's a bunch of Native
Americans they're living off the land
not hurting anybody you know so I don't
know I don't know how to I don't know
how to rationalize that I will tell you
this I don't know what the [ __ ] going
on as far as like everywhere I go they
got like they're building these luxury
high-rise apartments everywhere I go
luxury high-rise apartment first of all
what kind of a dumb [ __ ] would rent a
luxury apartment why wouldn't you just
buy a shitty house why are you gonna
take all that money and put it in
somebody else's pocket
not to mention who has the money to rent
a luxury
apartment you need a [ __ ] apartment
alright hey this all goes back to all of
these [ __ ] who is on TV walking
around with their big fake-ass lips
their fake [ __ ] tits ass is jacked up
in the air right these big stupid
designer everybody's living this
designer [ __ ] life all right let me
die dude I I
I realize how crazy I sound right now by
the way everybody I'm just gonna talk
until 60 minutes is up
and then I'm [ __ ] gonna put my giant
Charlie Brown's son stroke [ __ ] head
to bed alright I know a lot of you [ __ ]
right now you're enjoying this because
I'm sounded like I've walled myself off
and this authorities outside my house
right now I understand that I understand
on some level how crazy I sound it took
me about 17 minutes to [ __ ] and realize
it that this was a little [ __ ] nuts
they're not amazing being a comedian how
you can feel time I just looked down it
was eight 18 minutes 19 seconds anyways
after a while you can feel the club
owner staring at you like if he burns
his [ __ ] life I'm gonna end his
career and he's going back to his
[ __ ] day job you can feel it yeah
like I think they're just gonna build
all of these [ __ ] things and there's
not gonna be enough people that can
afford to live in them the whole [ __ ]
thing's gonna crash and this is what I
love it's all our money
these banker [ __ ] are doing it again
they did 10 years ago it collapsed with
the [ __ ] houses and now they're doing
it with these goddamn buildings and once
again it's our money and once again
they'll say we're too big to fail and
once again they'll write themselves
bonuses and they will just leave
nameless and faceless and then Steve
Carell is gonna have to start another
[ __ ] movie called what's the deal
with bankers part two right and do you
think that fat ass [ __ ] senator eaten
that sandwich at that [ __ ] pretzel
roll pushing his slacks down to just
above his pubic line it's
[ __ ] do anything about it I don't
think he is there you go buddy
there's a [ __ ] 19 minute [ __ ]
swirl a horse [ __ ] for you I had one of
the best shows of my career I'm not
gonna lie to you last night I had so
much goddamn fun that what used to be I
got to get this I got to get the name of
this casino correct all right
it used to be the Monte Carlo and then
the MGM bought it let's see a casino now
it's called the MGM something-or-other
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you where the hell is it I
am NOT gonna be able to find it
Volkov casino I'm an idiot I got right
Las Vegas okay all right hang on a
second Las Vegas Las Vegas [ __ ]
Nevada the park MGM is what it's called
now the Montecarlo is now called the
park MGM and I performed there with Joe
Bartnik Rosebowl tailgate legend Joe
bartnik we had a great time and it was
all these awesome amazing comics were in
town
Todd Rex the beige bendito as he calls
me calls himself we still got to do that
tour at some point the beige bandido and
the freckled [ __ ] all right again we had
the whole tour poster we had the whole
thing mapped out just haven't gotten
around to it yet anyways one of the
hardest people I've ever had to follow
in the business he swung by Ron White
was in town Dice Clay was in town it was
pretty [ __ ] awesome so anyways I went
there with my laughs my mother-in-law
came along and for the first time we we
actually had our daughter staying with
the god
Mada that was a little nerve-wracking
but uh you know we were only gone for a
day and came back I basically didn't see
her for maybe like 30 hours and uh it
was awesome was uh great to see her you
know dropped her off and I read her like
friggin like nine books that's my thing
you know it's funny like this is how
much like technology is just all over
everything like she was grabbing all
these books and I go let's let's let's
let's read a quiet book and it just
struck me is so funny cuz like all the
other ones have like sound effects and
you know the farmer he looked over and
he saw a and you pressed a button it's
like you gotta go rooster and then he
saw his man guy it's just like can't I
can't [ __ ] do that I don't know maybe
you know what it is these book people I
think they're feeling the pressure of
iPads not the authors probably the
people that make books they're like
we're doing what we can we're putting
books on Kindle but we're losing the
children okay is there a way that when
they read
I don't know Moby Dick is their way it
can there be like they turn the page and
water squirts at them like everything is
gonna turn into like a [ __ ] IMAX
movie I really try to limit the amount
of time my kid watches TV but she loves
the puppy dog pals and every time you
know she knows like our schedule like we
let her watch it in the morning she
watches puppy dog pals maybe a little
bit of Disney [ __ ] Mickey and Minnie
Mouse in vamp arena right and then
there's this Fancy Nancy thing I don't
know how I feel about that show you know
she's just really interested into
[ __ ] clothes and shoes and [ __ ] and
she's always trying to be the cool kid
but she's not and then she thinks if she
[ __ ] buy some [ __ ] or has some [ __ ]
made or she has the best [ __ ] tree
fort
it's just like what what the [ __ ] am i
watching so I finally said Taniya go the
IE you know I don't know if I like this
chick and you know this is why I love my
wife she's like can't you know I don't
know if I like I don't know if I like a
reader
you know she already said about another
like show she goes I don't like this
show I was like what's wrong with you
know like the you know like the
characters she goes no they always kind
of lie and do shifty [ __ ] to get what
they want and I was like wow she's
watching this on a whole other level
she's watching it as a parent so I
started watching him like that
oh shut up bill you watched Fancy Nancy
what you saw was an eight-year-old who
in the future looks like she's gonna
marry a guy because of how much money he
makes that's what you saw okay it has to
do with your issues with women that's
why you don't like the show all right
see that I don't need to go to therapy I
can get down to my own [ __ ] issues
myself so anyways I went on this
helicopter ride today up to the Zion
National Park and the [ __ ] that I saw I
saw this thing called the monkey Mesa
and it's a set of railroad tracks that
goes it has to go for like it looks like
for like three-quarters of a mile we
flew right over the [ __ ] thing and
when it gets and it goes right to the
edge of a cliff and just stops and back
in the day when NASA was testing out
parachutes and [ __ ] like that
they put a [ __ ] monkey on the thing
they'd send it down the track and they'd
shoot this poor [ __ ] monkey off the
goddamn cliff and if it lived the next
day you know like Chuck Yeager was like
did the monkey live all right I'll
[ __ ] give it a shot let's the balls
those guys had but you know what about
the monkey is it any wonder you know
someday they're gonna learn how to talk
and try to take us over I mean what the
[ __ ] we [ __ ] deserve it you don't
even give it a flight suit or a cool
nickname like maverick they just [ __ ]
throw it in there give it half a banana
think about how fast a monkey moves on
its own now all of a sudden it's getting
launched [ __ ] thing goes to space you
know they can do that [ __ ] now they look
at these ex football players and they
look at like the damage they've done to
the brains to CTE I want to take a
listen and I know that they can look at
your brain and see what stress does I
can't imagine
when a monkey comes back from [ __ ]
space you know that [ __ ] thing has
got to be just looking around like dude
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that you
just [ __ ] that monkey over for the
rest of it so they can't relate to
anybody you think you know the
astronauts they Diana enough of a
[ __ ] problem where after they went
out there the only other people they
could talk to was other astronauts what
they saw where they went what the [ __ ]
they did how scared they were how
exhilarating it was how much more they
believed in a [ __ ] higher power that
level of them experience and then they
come back and they try to hang out with
other human beings who we're all excited
go ahead you see the new Starbucks it
building and that's gonna be a really
nice one you know and then you you is
just sitting there you orbited the
[ __ ] earth and you got to try to hide
out how to enter the orbit of that
[ __ ] conversation without your brain
catching on fire man it's [ __ ] unreal
you know if you're sitting there going
what the [ __ ] is this guy talking about
I don't know what I'm talking about
either right so go [ __ ] yourself anyways
so we went in flew into Zion National
Park we actually set it down before we
got into the park we were trying to like
find a place to [ __ ] land I wanted to
stretch my legs and that's one of the
great things about flying a helicopter
is you really fly as far as how close
you can fly to [ __ ] if you just want to
set down somewhere you know we were so
[ __ ] hot we were actually looking at
this lake going you want to sit down I
just [ __ ] down I was like dude if I
had if I had packed a bathing suit I
would [ __ ] jump in that thing right
now in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere and
then he can do you know
but I like she wouldn't do because I'd
be too afraid a bear would come out of
nowhere [ __ ] mountain lion or some
[ __ ] you know but uh we flew over Lake
Mead who you always started Blake back
in the day the all the gangsters you
know that did all the people that the
mob would whack that they'd dump them
out there so write up a little bit on
that I don't know it's basically the
water that got backed up when they made
the Hoover Dam which I was not aware of
because I was thinking like how the [ __ ]
does this Lake exist out here oh that's
right once again we [ __ ] with nature
and you know as I sit there flying a
helicopter over blasting unleaded
unleaded fuel into the atmosphere
becoming part of the problem I'm not
pointing any fingers people okay
I'm as big a problem as anybody else
right so that lake is like on either
side of this mountain and in the middle
there's like a little valley that this
water goes through and we [ __ ] went
down and flew right up the thing okay
like some magnum p.i [ __ ] over people on
jet skis and boats it was incredible
it's [ __ ] incredible one of the
coolest things I ever I've done since
I've been in the helicopter and then we
flew up to Zion National Park and just
saw like remember those things they'd
sell you if you were tourists during the
summertime if you're in summertime kampl
they'd have all the different colors
sand and stuff they put it in a bottle
then your older brother would come up
and shake it up and you'd start crying
and be like but she was working two jobs
that she was too tired to do anything
about it I said work it out amongst
yourselves yeah like these these cliffs
look like that just these crazy
unbelievable colors unfortunately there
was a fire so there was a lot of smoke
and [ __ ] like just a lot of haze and
stuff so it wasn't as vivid but still it
was one of the most incredible things
I've seen but it was hot as [ __ ] man
I had on these these adidas that were
all black and my feet I had to keep you
know like once
every like 40 minutes you know I had to
give controls back to my instructor so I
could like move my feet to a shaded area
underneath the GPS system where I could
have my [ __ ] feet cool off I guess
that's why you know over in the Persian
Gulf army boots aren't black anymore
because it's your feet get too hot
that's why that they sort of the color
of Pete Carroll's pants isn't that
interesting
all right you know it's even more
interesting that ain't that [ __ ] I
was just talking is it's listening to me
read out loud Witcher now you're gonna
have to suffer through all right
everybody hotel to hotel tonight is the
go-to app for booking great deals at
great hotels yeah [ __ ] up is that song
is it called tonight and how much could
Phil Collins not miss that he just
picked he just says that word over and
over tonight anything grapefruit
grapefruit the whole [ __ ] stadiums
going nuts anyways unlike other hotel
booking sites Hotel tonight doesn't have
long endless lists of a zillion hotel
choices they know you don't have time
for that
instead Hotel 2 shows you only the best
deals at the best hotels they partner
with top-rated hotels to help them fill
their unsold rooms which is how you get
such great deals and even though the
name is hotel tonight it's not just for
tonight you could book tonight tomorrow
or beyond it's perfect for planners as
well as procrastinators you can book
spontaneous weekend's three-day get away
staycation road trips business trips you
can book a hotel just so you can use the
pool download the hotel too
app today to get great deals at hotels
you actually want to stay at and with
promo code burr you can get $25 off your
first first LOD eligible booking look at
that you booked yourself in a motel you
could probably stay there for seven
bucks and have money for a low-rent
hooker hotel two night promo code Burpee
URR oh look who's back Dollar Shave Club
do no matter what you do in the bathroom
to get ready dollar shave club has
everything you need to look and feel and
smell your best they have amazing shower
stuff haiya styling products
toothbrushes and toothpaste and of
course raises and shave supplies i'm
literally [ __ ] lightheaded i need to
drink some water that was out in the
elements all day today you might have
you might shave your whole body to get
ready for a bike race doll you might
have to shave your butt your whole body
get ready for a bike race Dollar Shave
club's executive and Shay can help you
might do your hair to get ready for your
soccer match
Boogie's by DSC can help you get your
style right oh god those days are long
gone for the [ __ ] freckled kid over
here the thing is no matter what you do
to get ready DSC has everything you need
and right now I'm so stupid I thought
DSC was like you know some outsource
thing you know like like an AMG Mercedes
they sent it to the AMG factory and
right now you can get ready with an
amazing deal on any of their their
starter sets like the daily essential
starter that but you can't go wrong with
any of them head over to
dollarshaveclub.com slash bar to pick up
your own Dollar Shave Club starter set
for just $5 after your starter set
product product ship at the regular
price and make sure you check out their
new video - that's jolly shape club.com
/ / jolly shape club.com / / b you are r
I'm not kidding man I'm [ __ ] light at
it maybe that's from screaming tonight
58 times bill you ever think about that
will do you alright oh the black tux
like The Ohio State University
the black tux wedding season is upon us
you're going to be doing it big and
going out to all your buddy's weddings
that's right you're not going to yours
good move when you're bringing a date
you want to look fresh but it has to be
convenient that's where the black tux
calm comes in the black tux has awesome
suits and tuxedos and all kinds of
styles and you rent them on line then
you put them on your body you go to the
wedding you pick up a chick you bang her
wearing most of the tuxedo then you
bring it back forgetting it ever
happened
the black tux offers the kind of suits
and tuxedos styles that would normally
be wildly expensive to buy and you might
only wear it once with the black tux you
can do you and blow it out for your big
one-time event so try out a new look do
something different and try your style
to the next level with the black tux
free home try on and try on you can see
the fit and feel the quality of your
suit months before your event after
ordering your suit after ordering your
suit will arrive 14 days before the
event if anything is less than perfect
the black tux will send you a
replacement right away and remember how
simple returns are wear it turn heads
then send it back three days after your
event shipping is free both ways to get
$20 off your purchase visit the black
tux comm / / that's the black tux comm /
/ for $20 off your purchase what do we
got left we got two reads left alright
let's give you a break you deserve it
after listening to my [ __ ] and
today's rambling there that was going
Alex Jones Anya wasn't I all right okay
Jane Fonda myth
I knew everybody's with that guy J dev
oh you never got [ __ ] he'd ever got
[ __ ] tortured alright just a note I
love your work really please do you
exist on the planet I'm no historian but
some comments that Tom Rhodes made on
your recent podcast about Jane Fonda
didn't sound realistic to me so I looked
it up
turns out they would not maybe you can
correct Tom so he doesn't continue to
perpetuate this myth listen I've known
Tom too long to try to correct him I'm
sure Jane Fonda had her faults but my
guess is she tried her best to be a good
a good person and to fight for peace on
her planet who wrote this Jane Fonda
might be she is as heroic in her own way
has some as those on the prowl jesus
[ __ ] christ
Jesus Christ on the battlefield oh yeah
a starlet going to the enemy you know as
opposed to some guy who's [ __ ] poor
so he has to go to the front [ __ ]
lines yeah yeah maybe maybe they're both
yes heroic I can see that you know to me
like me doing this podcast I think in a
lot of ways I'm sort of like a Navy SEAL
you know sir I understand what you're
saying I am I am a pacifist too I really
do not I don't understand why war is
legal okay and I just think it's the
temper tantrum of rich people is all a
war is okay I'm not saying that's not
crazy psycho [ __ ] people they get in
power and need to be stopped that
there's also that okay but a lot of
times it's just a [ __ ] land grab are
you going after some sort of natural
resource okay I know what to tell you
all right but having said that all right
you know once the troops are on the
ground if you want to [ __ ] [ __ ]
about it
go to your politician all right go file
for a permit to protest 90 miles away
from where any media coverage is that's
the way it's done
okay what you don't do is go to Saddam
Hussein's house and have the guy cook
you a [ __ ] meal you know while all
this server it's a quiver and you go hey
you know he's not even that bad of a
[ __ ] guy you know or maybe you dope
but at no point do you feel it's [ __ ]
heroic it's some poor [ __ ] bastard
all right trying to piss a cop I think
once you're wearing leg warmers they
though I don't think you're a hero
anymore
all right met a girlfriend on tape dear
Billy balloon tits I'll have you guys
[ __ ] know I'm in the best goddamn
[ __ ] shape I've been in and I sense I
don't know how long all right I'm
getting my ABS back okay I'm getting a
little sick of the body shaming here on
the Monday morning podcast I go out of
my way to not research on Jane Fonda I
would think that you guys would do a
little more research on what I'm looking
like lately all right the last three
weeks
okay listen to your pot your last
podcast and heard all the trashing
dating sites and tinder well I may be a
dude but I wanted to offer my take on
the matter I have never gotten so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] in my life I'm kidding he
didn't say all right since it's not all
serial killers and fuck-boy weirdos on
this sites on these sites fuck-boy
weirdos is I don't know this is that's
got to be the name of like a punk band
or something
first off let's make one thing clear
there are shitty women on these sites -
oh thank you god bless you gotta love
somebody that tries to balance it out
here I know guys get and probably
deserve most of the heat but girls
catfish guys all the time in these sites
plus there are the girls on this these
sites who only want attention slash
money and have no intention of actually
going out and meeting new people second
I met my girlfriend of almost a year on
tinder and we couldn't be happier
we were initially embarrassed to admit
to our friends and family that we met
this way but afterwards I had several
people talk about how they
successful relationships blossom from
these sites my cousin met her husband
and father of her child on
christianmingle.com no joke Jesus Christ
you know you think the Christians could
come up with a better [ __ ] name
Christian mingle that sounds too much
like Dingle and you just picture a
priest playing with some [ __ ] poor
kids balls I don't know bill it was it
was just Catholic Church it wasn't all
the other Christianity was it by yeah
you're probably right anyways and I
learned that my two friends met on
bumble after we told them we met on
tinder yeah well you that's all
everybody's on their [ __ ] phones
anyways you go to a night club and
people are on their phones alright you
want to meet her you got to get in the
phone you can't be standing there being
an actual person I think it freaks these
Millennials up third tinder is a great
way to cut through all the [ __ ] of
blind dating or hitting on chicks who
you have nothing in common with at meat
market bars dating sites are also great
if you're single in a new city without
many friends to go out with like I was
in conclusion peace of people should
stop all the hate on dating sites just
because their relationship failed or
because they never tried it love you and
your comedy bill come back to Philly and
go [ __ ] yourself alright thank you sir
well there you go I mean I think we [ __ ]
on these [ __ ] sites enough it was
nice to hear you know that was a point
in a little bit counterpoint all right
Isis bicycling a bait Billy white tits
all right I'll take that have you heard
of the story of the couple that went
bicycling and Taz chica Stan they tried
to prove that people are actually good
at heart and ended up getting stabbed to
death what the [ __ ] if you haven't heard
of it yet I'll attach an article for you
if you want to try to read it thanks for
all the laughs during the podcast and go
[ __ ] yourself all right I don't
understand what
you know oh my god is this real
it's on people people dot-com
it looks like the People magazine logo
but God knows the Internet you could
just curate that and use it for yourself
American couple who spent life savings
to bike around the world killed in ice
in Isis claimed attack I'm not gonna say
these poor people's names we're living
out their dream of traveling the world
bicycling tragically while out doing
what they loved with five other cyclists
their quest was cut short when they will
run over and stabbed to death by armed
men in Tajikistan on Sunday let's see
here the woman's parents confirmed in a
statement to CBS News that the couple
who were both 29 were killed in the
attack Isis claimed responsibility for
the attack two other tourists Dutch and
Swiss Nationals were killed while three
riders survived NPR reports these two
people started their journey in 2017
they first biked
through Africa Europe and Central Asia
before finding themselves in Tezuka Stan
using all of their life savings to fund
their trip the couple also documented
their travels on the blog simple simply
cycling the year-long bicycling
adventure with the woman and her partner
were in June they were enjoying was
typical of their enthusiasm blah blah
blah okay well where does it say that
they thought the world was nice
I don't get this any longer here's a
quote you watched the news and you read
the papers and you led to believe that
the world is a big scary place people
the narrative goes are not to be trusted
people are bad people evil people are
axe murderers and monsters and worse he
wrote badness exists sure but even
that's quite rare by and large humans
are kind this is still true how many
people did they bicycle past before one
cut in a car ended their [ __ ] life
lives self-interest interested sometimes
myopic sometimes but kind generous and
wonderful and kind no greater revelation
has come from our journey than this
yeah that's true that is true and they
got killed because you know basically of
our foreign [ __ ] policy you know
there's a lot of people out there that
don't like [ __ ] Americans and there's
a lot of evil [ __ ] twisted people out
there what those people were that killed
those other people who the [ __ ] knows
you know yeah this you know there's how
you wish the world was and the way it
really is and you have to act
accordingly alright and you have to know
when you're doing something like that
that there is that chance that that
could [ __ ] happen yeah this you know
yeah most people I've always said that
just walking around they try to get a
sandwich they're trying to find love you
know and we sit down and you watch TV
you watch the news you get all [ __ ]
hysterical and but to make no mistake
there are some really fucked-up people
out there and some of them are in this
country and some of them are not but
they're out there that's too bad sound
like they almost made it around the
world or at least that side of the world
right I don't know
alright boyfriend is [ __ ] up big time
okay hey Bill lady listen err I love
when the ladies write it
desperate for some relationship help so
I'm getting straight to the point
my boyfriend is about to lose me and I'm
desperate to get through to him we are
30 been together two years
both want to eventually marry each other
have babies together etc the issue we
need to help with is his ex-girlfriend
they dated for three years broke up then
remained extremely close friends yeah
that that's [ __ ] [ __ ] they had
been broken up for a little over a year
when I initially came into the picture
my boyfriend told me about her but
originally told me they were friends and
completely failed to mention that they
were once a couple all right okay
and you were 28 at the time so I'll
forgive you all right but now you're 30
and you got to read the tea leaves here
I don't need to read the rest of this I
asked but I will I actually found out
from her because she saw his flirting on
Instagram and then messaged me she's a
nice enough woman who now lives with her
boyfriend over the last two years I've
met her several times and while I didn't
particularly love the way she looks at
my man I'm not going to be a [ __ ] about
it either oh you are not being a [ __ ]
on any level what you are being is too
[ __ ] accommodating she and I used to
text quite a bit quite often oh god
she's probably milking you for
information but that has come to an
abrupt stop because I've been become fed
up with how close she and my boyfriend
still are are you gonna tell me at night
you're sitting there watching TV with
him and she calls and then he talks to
her for like 20 30 40 minutes in the
beginning of our relationship they would
hang out constantly
they lived in California and lived in
Colorado and I lived in Colorado so my
boyfriend and I were in a long-distance
relationship for over a year until he
recently moved to Colorado to start a
life with me when he was still living in
California he and his ex would go out to
eat go shopping go to concerts or even
go on road trips together now what are
the odds that they weren't is still
[ __ ] at that point they had a shared
hobby of photography so they would often
take photos of each other as well yes
this became an issue a huge issue I
would I would say things like I get that
you guys are friends but I feel like you
are going on a date like things with her
when you are dating me and he would
always reply with I wish I could take
you but I can't because of the distance
so am I supposed to never
go out and do anything oh my god [ __ ]
this guy and he would guilt me and then
manipulate the situation until I
essentially had to be okay with it
yeah okay you know I gotta be honest
with you this is you this isn't him he's
a [ __ ] but I mean you gotta [ __ ] come
on maybe the fact that I'm reading your
own words out loud right now you can see
how obvious this is yeah [ __ ] this guy
fast forward to now obviously they don't
hang out like they used to do to him
moving in Colorado but they still text
all the time I've talked to my boyfriend
about this and how it bothers me I say
look I know you and whoever were very
close she's a good person so are you I
know you guys have a lot of history and
I know that I knew about her from the
beginning of our relationship with you
about it did you ever ask him that how
come he didn't say you [ __ ] used to
date this person you're shifty [ __ ]
however what I didn't realize is how
close you two would remain maybe I'm
naive
naive but I thought that naturally as
you and I grew closer you and so-and-so
would grow more distant and you would
focus only on our relationship bill and
I my in my eyes I'm pretty cool
girlfriend for knowing that my man and
his ex are close friends but the airport